So far,
we've seen a 25 new billion dollar startups on pace with lash that could attract
a price tag of $9 billion raised that we just announced this week,
our $18 million pitch book.
This is shaping up to be the biggest year for uniform IPL.
So you are seeing some private stock market site equity at
$7.2 billion is over
$6 million.
My name is Jonathan mot. Uh, people call me Joma and I'm, uh,
starting a startup.
What made you decide you want to start a startup?
Yeah, well, I've always worked for companies like Facebook, Microsoft, you know,
big tech companies.
And I always had this itch of starting something on my own.
So after working for Buzzfeed, the idea of a startup,
like it was growing on me, you know,
every day I just kept thinking about it and I couldn't stop at the
point where like my visions were so vivid that it was almost like
reality.
So about this vision. Can you talk to me a little bit more about that?
Like what is your startup idea?
Yeah, it's a, it's a,
it's a tech startup and um, well,
Y man just started, so I don't really have a
[inaudible].
Coming up with a startup a year, usually starts with a problem.
And that problem is usually when you have yourself.
So that's why today we're going to be thinking about problems. Now,
according to Paul Graham, the co-founder of the seed capital from Y Combinator,
best startup ideas tend to be something that founders want and something they
can build themselves. So what are the advantages of choosing a problem?
You have yourselves. Well, first and foremost,
ensures the problem really exists. And second of all,
it makes it a lot easier for you to develop empathy for your users.
Another important aspect is how much do users need or product.
It's better to have a few people who absolutely need your product than having a
lot of people who might want your product.
Obviously you want to build something that reaches a lot of people and they
really need it.
But most of those ideas are already implemented like Google for searching the
web. That's why having a well-defined problem that real people have is vital for
coming up with a killer startup idea. However,
this requires some research planning, finding potential stakeholders, though.
These are crucial steps for building a successful startup.
Sometimes as an engineer, you just can't help yourself. But to start building,
We were going to Stanford,
we're going to go see what my friends I'm going to see if he's,
if he's interested.
And working with me.
He's just a sophomore, but, uh, he's a very talented individual.
[Inaudible] Stanford home of the unicorn startups,
the Gryffendor of universities, the smarter brother of UCB. What not to love.
Look at that grass. Imagine feeding that grass to cow and then eating that cow.
Oh man.
Brandon I'm Brandon Tron.
I'm a student at Stanford. I studied some box systems and I do software stuff.
Is this your room? Yeah, this is messy.
I know Joe, after working at Buzzfeed with him, uh,
I was an intern there this summer and he hung out with the interns a lot
anyways. Um, so yeah, I came here to ask you a couple of questions cause uh, I,
she want to talk to you about something.
He came over here to talk to me about a project you wanted to work on.
I got start up date as you know, um, if you saw my video,
uh, I'm starting to yeah. Sorry to start off. So yeah, so it's pretty exciting.
Um, I'm pretty excited about it. What's what's the idea? Well, well, I mean,
like, I don't have like a full idea yet and like,
I'm still kind of like working on that.
Like one of the reasons why I don't want to talk about it is like,
I don't really think I should talk about it, you know, on camera. So,
so I think, okay, so I'll just tell you that. Okay.
Yeah. So we
kind of idea, but uh,
I think Joel was a pretty smart dude, so, uh,
we'll see. Uh, it's an idea, but like, okay. Like,
would you use it for example? I doubt it,
but, but, but, but you're not the target demographic, you know, but yeah,
no, you're not. Okay. Well, I mean, obviously you're not,
since you don't think you would use it, but like imagine if it does succeed,
think about how awesome it is or, you know yeah.
That's exceed. It would be really cool. It would be pretty Epic.
Like I could see it shouldn't do it. It's like,
you don't always want to be the co-founder of something,
especially in this space where it's like, it's a hit or miss,
so it could just be the headline, like, yo, this startup kind of sucks.
Personally. I do want you to drop out, you know,
because you do know that people who drop out of Stanford have a 50% higher
chance of being a founder of a huge IPO unicorn.
I feel company, I would think, I don't think that's true. I mean like,
think about it, you know, you've got, you know, Snapchat. Okay. Um,
uh, so, so,
so I guess like you don't think you can like put in a hundred percent kind of a
thing. Yeah. Probably not. It seems like a really redundant idea.
Think something that's kind of already been done before, so yeah. Right, right.
Okay. Yeah. Uh, yeah.
I asked if you talked with her for that and it's free dinner. Oh yeah. Sure,
sure. Okay. Well I guess, uh, well like yeah, like just think about it,
you know, sleep on it and uh, yeah. But like thanks for,
thanks for letting me know. But, uh, all right. Yes.
So I'm excited to see where it goes. Yeah.
Yeah, no worries.
But I would want to help out on the video stuff.
Maybe I got pretty interested in that. Yeah. I think it was a cool concept.
Wait, like you want to do like the video stuff,
like you mean like the blog that I'm doing, right? Yeah.
I think that's a cool concept. Yeah, sure. I mean like,
just like on a production standpoint. Well, I mean,
like if that's what you're interested, like I definitely need help on that.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I'm done. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, because I have no one right now.
Oh yeah, yeah. No, that'd be super helpful. Yeah. All right. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Yeah. Nice. All right. Sweet.
Despite not being able to convince my friend to be a co-founder,
at least I know that people are still willing to help in some form.
Maybe finding a co-founder just, isn't the best thing to do right now.
Maybe the best thing to do.
Right now is just to keep grinding.
Now, if you enjoyed this video, don't forget to press the like button.
And then if you want to see more of these blogs or you want to see what happens
to my startup,
then don't forget to subscribe to my channel so that you get notified when new
episodes come out. But yeah, have a good day.
Great.